the cross-examination of Lucy letby
continued today focusing on a baby girl
She's accused of trying to murder four
times before she eventually died the
prosecution alleged that letby fatally
injected the baby with air at the
counters of Chester Hospital in October
2015 claims the nurse vigorously denies
today here at Manchester Crown Court the
prosecution claimed that Lucy let be
falsified timings on care notes in order
to as they put it cover her tracks the
court heard that on the night that baby
I died Lucy letby wasn't the child's
designated nurse and had instead been
assigned to look after other babies in
different rooms on the neonatal Ward
but the prosecution says despite that
medical notes show that it was Lucy
letby that was by the child cot side
alone when she suddenly deteriorated
that's the truth isn't it that you were
in there when child eye was crying
relentlessly and no one else was there
the prosecution said potentially yes let
B replied
the former nurse was also questioned
about her behavior after the child had
died the court had a statement from the
baby's mother who was bathing her dead
child on the ward and said
Lucy came back in she was smiling she
kept going on about how she was present
at child eye's first bath and how much
she loved it
it wasn't meant with any malice Lucy
letby said we still talk to babies we
still treat them like they are alive I
was just trying to reflect on a happier
memory but the prosecution said you were
getting a thrill watching that the grief
the despair you were watching in that
room weren't you absolutely not the
former nurse replied
prosecution questioning of Lucy letby
will continue next week over what
happened between June 2015 and 2016 she
denies the murder of seven babies and
the attempted murder of ten others
Catherine Sky News in Manchester